citizens of the reject Nation it is John it
is a Roxy and we are back for yet another
installment of the Ip Man franchise it Man
3 starring Donald the Yen Roxy thank you for
joining me how are you today can you do your
theory thing that you do three yeah and I
even got the r roll how are you doing today
are you feeling good I I sent Greg a text
message lying to him saying that I watched
this beforehand to see if he would freak out
and he did good it was a lie though I haven't
seen it yet but I've been patiently waiting
I loved it man one I loved it man too I'm
gonna be very upset if this isn't good absolutely
we if it's not good we Riot but before we
find out whether it's good or not I think
you guys could at least do us a favor and
leave a like on the video as well subscribe
to the channel hit that notification Bell
And subscribe to the World Girls follow Roxy
on social media find out everything she's
doing if you want to be with us in the present
why don't you come over to patreon.com the
real reject sync up with your own copy of
Hitman 3 enjoy all the things that don't make
these reaction highlights the real blast over
there are you ready to do this oh yeah oh
yeah action time this is weird martial arts
Kool-Aid man yeah we're gonna do the action
[Music]
Mike Tyson that's right I wonder how he's
gonna fit into this world The Hangover not
this movie hey you never know
always training always keeping those Basics
strong of all three of the movies started
with him on this yeah device that you and
I don't know what it's called people commented
and I and I should have pulled it for this
exact occasion but thank you for letting us
know
I mean another one
[Laughter] um
yeah so Bruce Lee time
I
hate it it's okay you can't be perfect
whoa
smoke fight even the cigarette can be Kung
Fu
wow
oh [Laughter]
Wowie
[Laughter]
okay fire y
that's the question
very philosophical question well almost Batman
him
hmm was that a no Legend it's a no for now
are you a die-hard Bruce Lee fan I got a big
respect for Bruce Lee definitely seen some
iconic fights but I haven't seen a lot of
full Bruce Lee films actually me neither I've
seen a lot more Jackie Chan
oh
[Music] oh yeah
manga
it's busy working all day what's a rickshaw
polar I think Rickshaw is one of those carts
that you you know hold on to and run with
yeah
oh he's hungry
oh little guy yeah you could see how he was
looking at it
I wonder how that's gonna sit with his pride
something that would never happen in the states
they give your kid to another family you know
just go home and have dinner with these folks
for a while No One's Gonna sue us for kidnapping
negligence
foreign
[Music]
they found like the most gorgeous actors of
all time for these movies oh [Applause]
wow [Music] oh here we go
it's a smart move of Mike Tyson to be in this
movie oh sure do you notice that Master app
is living in luxury again or at least comfortably
yeah I'm glad for him me too open it up okay
you did good what about that other business
foreign
bet your ass it is whoa no the people in the
comments also told me that Wing Chun was invented
by a woman yeah named for her and now a priestess
if I'm not mistaken thank you rejects
oh no no
yeah
she deserves a date the best wife in the world
[Laughter] we've all had that moment
[Music]
[Music] a
lifelong dabbler
this guy's got a lot to prove yeah [Music]
normally
between the two of us
oh
dude
ah dude
laughs
gonna miss your kid [Music]
make a sternly worded call your boss
here they are total thugs
um
appreciate your help
teach them outside in the streets
foreign we got that look yeah Love Is in the
Air
Haunted Mansion this haunted room actually
stretching unbelievable voice you just did
dead ringer
oh come on
hmm
[Laughter] oh
damn it oh my God what do they have in their
hands gasoline probably
Why I oughta
oh damn
whoa no leave this poor man alone they're
just trying to teach the kids God every time
he does that I know I can't even move that
quickly I know right I feel like I just did
good
I'm gonna watch your skills grow over these
reactions
like how do you smoke cigarettes and do that
your stamina is unbelievable yeah it's like
training in the mountains
nice I really like this guy's Style
[Laughter] he's awesome yeah [Music]
caught in those like dual kicks yeah
what time is it I mean I guess people always
need transport but yeah think about Ubers
o all right I don't know if this is luxury
but you know but nice nicer than the whole
from last time yes
oh someone's not getting laid tonight don't
miss a date I know man heels are so many dates
yeah
if
[Music]
damn I don't like her she was so judgy I know
he's a hard worker clearly keeps his head
down too the investigation into the school
I will take care of it because I am in charge
because I am the most British man who's ever
lived and therefore I am evil
what foreign
oh
damn yeah
you've done it huh uh no no
foreign
[Music]
auntie how do I join oh bad luck do you
think that was an improv moment yeah I bet
that was I don't think you meant to do that
I bet they just kept it because it was real
yeah
she deserves the biggest bestest date of all
time after all this is done like what are
you thinking like I don't know some kind of
magical foreign getaway maybe all she wants
is a little dance class Little Things did
he just leave a tip
[Music] he's asking for another favor it's
not a tip at all yeah
she's so into the paper [Laughter] that's
funny yes that's a good clap back
yeah I was gonna guess that no who can she
talk to feel so bad for us like she deserves
a break from all this anguish
go to him to him don't suffer in silence
oh damn it
oh don't go to the dark side
of this full of bills they're all like different
sizes I know yeah like how much is that really
no dude
no
of course what a shot yeah
I hate this yeah
oh no oh use the umbrellas as Weapons yeah
ah get in the music hated that hated it hate
it hate it good storytelling I hate it I hope
there's a Redemption Arc somewhere there's
gonna be that guy because he's not evil and
that wouldn't be an Ant-Man movie
huh you missed last words
and your wife is not well oh he's going to
find out here these [__]
[Music]
no that's how they get you don't don't watch
the Nickelodeon [Music]
run oh my God they're just they're just wholesale
swiping them up oh
dude
[__] you've been had
um
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no what happened
[Music] foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's get it done
like his son's on the line you think he's
gonna mess it up this time nah man he's in
the zone
[Music] yeah drink up that motivation that
kid is probably scared shitless oh yeah
[Music] finally call him son no he didn't
no I'm just I'm waiting for him to finally
call him son yeah his disciple what you call
your your pupils always I think it's just
indicative of what kind of relationship they
have yeah damn this is like a a boat in construction
like the hull of an unbuilt ship it's cool
wow
oh nice this is messed up man
dude yes go go yes you knew he wasn't gonna
be bad [__] you knew
[Music]
nice
I
love this guy yeah and just the I hate that
I feel dead but yeah it's like the way it
fights you can feel the grace and this guy
you could just feel the impact yeah like very
like raw
in that bright red coat Jesus kids are just
so helpless yeah okay [Music] yes yes
oh
geez yeah get high The High Ground kick him
kick him
please it's like Papa's trying homie yeah
wow
yes I guess maybe this makes up for missing
the date sure saving our son's life from 150
plus assassins
oh boy oh nice
oh yeah I'm getting out of here
I'm just gonna take myself out
yet [Music]
real [__] show huh let him go can't the
kids say like he helped yeah step up little
ones [Music] I would cry too yeah this kid's
got to be traumatized he's gonna PTSD for
the rest of his life
[Music] oh boy that's that was a tough moment
yeah
come on it's not really your fault you're
a protector of the people and it probably
will happen again unfortunately yeah and you
can't even say I promise it was the last time
yeah he says it was my fault poor thing she's
like probably going through the same thought
process right now which is like I cannot stand
what you did that you got our son almost injured
but then you saved him and also I'm super
sick and I haven't told you and now doesn't
feel like the right time and I realize that
things are messed up the way things are run
around here but also you don't have to fight
every battle I don't want to sew on your goddamn
button so [Music] hold on authentic oh poor
thing she is a great actress
foreign
[Music]
enough how sad I am right now about this should
be my favorite character from the beginning
even though like she's not like the biggest
part of the plot like she just has like such
presence and Grace and she is like the ink
Rock yeah these movies do such a great job
mixing in like real things real drama yeah
yeah real life
[Music] it's nice to see them together yeah
after so long this is horrible that's what
it took time being all this nefarious Vice
and Corruption that you people too love to
engage yourself in you'll have to take a Hiatus
otherwise frankham Frank here I can't I almost
forgot Mike Tyson was in this movie yeah he's
had like three lines yep
koi
oh oh Christ
not oh my God
ah you uptake these
wow
God
such a tight space we haven't seen something
like this yet Jesus
no
the helmet yes
protect there goes the best damn husband this
country's ever seen
well
those little punch zooms
oh
whoa wow oh in his mind he's like you try
to hurt my sick wife I kill you yeah you mess
with the wrong dude
it's another casual day as it man I mean it
does seem like this is what his life is like
the people challenging him or else major crime
that needs intervened upon
goody
going right to the top let's see who fists
are the fastest yours a mind some fun Joe
if you laugh by then often go away the ADR
props for for doing the interlinguals with
him but also yeah
wow Ace
that's a hard you just got such a power punch
man like yeah Iron Mike
yeah oh damn dude whoa whoa oh no careful
kiddo
wow
sure
somebody ever did that in real life it would
be very intimidating yeah I feel like that's
not as common as it used to be oh he gets
so far down Get Low can you do that probably
not right now but I'm gonna practice
whoa interesting [Music] ah nice yes yes oh
ouch ouch like he hit all that glass of nothing
yeah
that's right work it out
[Music]
wow whoa
got your nuts dusted right there I feel like
it was in Tyson's contract he was like I don't
have to win but I can't lose yeah that look
he gave him just then too yes
why don't you come in and train and you can
meet them that way because women don't train
what don't you understand I know silly
of me
foreign
[Music] journalistic Integrity very important
whoa boy oh my God
wow
God the way this dude moves oh he got his
bell wrong yeah got your wish
God
the way the camera work has evolved is fascinating
yeah and the colors yeah
two
wow what a what a meanwhile montage
where is this command how is he here every
time yeah yeah this is personal photographer
now is the Jimmy Olsen of kung fu he calls
him be there in five yes
a little
um
foreign
I want it man to say no my wife is sick I
don't feel like fighting today caring for
my wife is the true Wing Chun okay
[Music] [Laughter]
that's pretty funny that's a good one I love
when people in movies tell jokes and when
they're actually funny yeah Good Will Hunting
sitting at the table mini driver these foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you
think they haven't told their kid yeah I don't
think they've told him yet okay what age do
you do that I don't know some of these experimental
treatments gotta work
jeez man I do love the contrast of of the
side by side In this passage with Chung On
The Rise and IP just living family life
or hormone
interesting I didn't open the door so you'd
leave I guess so that you'd feel free to come
in at any time okay my door is open too maybe
but
did it man even accept I feel like he could
easily just not show up to this foreign
[Music] yes yes who cares miss the fight dance
it up I love it [Music] this is great great
character development I mean I know we come
to these for the amazing fights largely but
I I'm so happy just to watch them damn like
I watch a new wave movie of them just dancing
and living life yeah yeah this other dude's
gonna feel so disrespected [Music]
by technicality de facto winner
traditionalist
s are 18.
interesting wow that was a
clever way to twist it yeah
oh no [Applause] no no
[Music] oh no whoa
[Music] it's a deafening silence it's good
they got that dancing but yeah [Music] how
are you
never gonna make it out yeah I'm gonna keep
holding out hope that one of these like treatments
they've sought will work but I don't I don't
think that's what's gonna happen oh they're
not doing anything this is why Superman works
best when his dad dies of a heart attack and
not when he could have saved his dad it's
like you know we there's nothing he can do
sure it is very uh you just have to kind of
accept the present moment we've seen him win
every single fight but this isn't a fight
yeah you can't bargain with this yeah because
we kept wondering like you know at some point
it man has to lose right oh well yeah and
and in the way you didn't think he was right
yeah oh
oh
dressed up one more time [Music] oh [Music]
got it oh [Music] so you think she's gonna
die and then he's gonna fight I guess that's
how the structure is feeling right now I wonder
what she put in that note though or do you
think he's gonna fight and she's gonna see
him win one last time she passes away while
he's fighting oh
[Music] yeah
that's a bar let me show you let's see okay
show you later
and to Wing Chun [Music]
oh sure how single does this movie make you
feel quite we should all be so lucky to have
a love like this boy
nice that's what was in the letter [Music]
oh she's so supportive and perfect that's
beautiful a couple goals serious she knows
she's leaving the Earth and she's like what
am I leaving him with
yeah all he's gonna have is his wooden man
and uh and the kids but you know she's not
the same yeah where is the kid we don't know
[Music] whatever this instrument is to like
is one of the most beautiful and heartbreaking
sounds like it almost sounds like a voice
but I feel like it's some kind of string sounds
like a what violent it almost sounds like
a voice a voice but it also yeah it feels
like it could be a stringed instrument or
something I would love just the frequency
of the sound of him hitting the wood is what
it takes to cure her cancer we're open on
him local man this doesn't feel like that
kind of movie though
this place looks sick yep how are you feeling
about him right now this is a fascinating
character I really like the way they've drawn
him as this guy who like you could see how
everyone's getting upset like oh man you know
you're so cocky but he just seems burdened
by a purpose and a philosophy and not evil
keep one guy at that moment too
[Music] honor among Wing Chun people sure
[Music]
whoa
the lens work on these fights is fascinating
oh
this floor is amazing yeah
oh nice
these two you called that they'd be homies
let's watch my dad beat up your dad and your
dad beat up my dad [Music]
some wild sound design
[Music] wow
cool [Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I feel like hitman's always in that black
and this other guy's been in the white and
now yeah it's almost like they've traded
that noise was intense yeah what are you gonna
move to no knives drop the knives just bare
fists man
[Music] wow
[Music] yeah this is what we've been waiting
for oh yeah this is it let's go stop messing
around
with a good elbow yeah wow
dang
wow
oh
they're gonna knock each other out at some
point
[Music] wow
oh no bueno
whoa
whoa oh
my God the wattage parts
oh put that in your pocket for Bruce Lee oh
my God
is he calling it over I don't know I think
he's yeah he's really going it over oh my
God
yoga
[Music] but
then he's double defeated who's the love of
his life his kid his kid It's gotta be his
disciple maybe he'll finally call him son
oh same way to do this Montage yeah
greatest hits of their love a very music video
like slideshow music video-esque I do appreciate
this I mean if she's if the character is gonna
die I mean and she's been like we've loved
her so much throughout the year why do you
keep saying if she's learned to accept understood
such denial you don't take this from me you
said fighting's gonna bring her back it is
oh 1960.
damn the one fight he couldn't win yeah
oh [Music]
damn
there's another winner man seriously I know
but that one left you uh oh you're good oh
yeah I mean I'm a little drained but I'm good
no I mean that was that was gripping and epic
and and touching and emotional and yeah and
it didn't go it didn't go the places I was
expecting in terms of like you know the big
bads and the and like I feel like the other
two movies you have a much more clear set
of like historical circumstances where it's
like okay the Japanese and it's like you know
first you got squabbling schools and then
the Japanese invade then you have to deal
with that tyranny and then you move to Hong
Kong and we've got you know the British who
are exercising their own form of tyranny here
and then in this one like I thought it was
gonna grow to like okay Mike Tyson and whatever
this sort of mob Arrangement is that you know
is clearly controlling this area and you know
inhibiting the law and things like that like
I thought it was gonna be like oh he's gonna
have to fight Mike Tyson at the end for you
know some kind of you know liberation from
this you know mob tyranny and then for it
to become a much more personal thing after
that I thought was really interesting the
Mike Tyson thing was interesting because he
was barely in the movie and also it was um
the one like draw essentially right I feel
like that probably was very strictly contractually
speaking um which is fine because it's not
like he just tried uh distracts me it or it
doesn't detract from the movie yeah but he
really had nothing to do with the overarch
the overall like themes of the movie which
the guy at the end I don't remember what his
name is the guy that I liked the whole time
yeah Chung Chung he was just so different
than our other our other antagonists because
he's not evil he's not trying to take over
the country or the city you know and you can
see him dealing with the circumstances of
what life is like here now too yeah like I
loved that they have him I don't think a wild
card is exactly the right descriptor but you
have him you know at first falling in with
uh this this gang at the Western Union who
you know is clearly trying to Stranglehold
the community and then you know he sees you
know the the the error in that I mean like
At first yeah it's means to an end I gotta
feed my kid and and I like that they don't
give you too much backstory on him you can
kind of fill in the blank based on how he
behaves what his relationship with his son
is like how he's trying to provide um but
yeah watching him go in with them at first
and then realize like oh no they're locking
kids up and stuff and this is really this
is truly you know evil immoral and evil and
heinous yeah and I can't stand for that and
and how could I be an honorable Master how
could I you know arise to the station and
to the reputation I want to hold if I'm you
know a Lackey in this organization completely
his whole thing is he's trying to be the best
right he just wants to be the best at what
he does and provide for his kid so it's when
you look at it like that knowing that he was
under the same thumb that um Ip Man had been
under previously you know he lived a whole
life before this moment as well yeah you feel
for him and you realize like he this is a
single father trying to provide for his kid
through really tough times yeah and and show
that he represents this this schooling that
he has gone through um and it man's fighting
his own separate battle Which is less of a
financial battle at this point more of a internal
Battle of do I help the community do I help
my family do I help the community to help
my family and then ultimately that decision
is made for him when he finds out that his
wife is sick yeah yeah of course and like
the way they Incorporated that too like the
way this does go from being the kind of Ip
Man movie you're not used to in a bad way
but it's like you know it feels like The Logical
next step in it man you know series and then
to shift into something much more sort of
quietly dramatic and much more emotionally
impactful I thought was a nice contrast like
I I could almost imagine people being taken
aback at first by that but yeah going from
these two movies where you culminate in these
big public battles to then just this last
portion where this guy has his whole own rise
on the side and then you're just watching
as you know it man and his wife make up for
lost time and just like the the beautiful
like I like that they brought in some new
uh New Wave feeling flourishes to that where
you are just kind of watching them dance and
watching them live a little bit and revisiting
these moments that we have spent so much time
on and and eat rice as a family like have
dinner together because it has not been making
it home for dinner things like that yeah and
like the way that they don't really have to
get in your face with a dramatic like you're
never here you're always fighting other people's
battle even though it's there and even though
you can feel the impact and the weight of
it and the sort of difficulty of like the
all the things we love about Ip Man probably
make him kind of a difficult husband I would
imagine right definitely I was thinking that
during the movie like should some of the best
people in the world not have families because
they are so altruistic and dedicated to society
um and I don't believe that about it man because
I think he obviously did such an amazing job
especially about finding that balance yeah
but it has got to be very hard when you put
upon yourself the well-being of thousands
because he really does of all of the in every
single movie is of his whole town of its all
the children it's of all the students it's
all you know like it's all the people yeah
and and sometimes that means that you don't
get to put your loved ones first and sometimes
that puts your loved ones in a difficult position
as we see happens here like you know his kid
gets taken strategically his wife is placed
in danger like when you are a visible public
figure the way that this guy is and you happen
to inhabit a world where fighting and having
to defend the honor of your Technique is a
frequent thing like yes it's got to be a kind
of scary life to live if you're anybody but
that guy completely completely I feel like
the the general message and I talked about
this a little throughout the movie but like
you know they say um man makes plans God laughs
or whatever I think the general message of
this is like you can train your entire life
you can train to win every single fight and
you're still going to be handed a fight that
you cannot win it's an unwinnable fight and
that is what happened here especially for
the time period you know now we hear cancer
and you don't hear you don't think like goner
back then as yes it's not as as much of like
an immediate like oh no there's not really
anything we can do then you go into fight
mode but back then it you go into live mode
like okay we only have so few time left we
have to live we're trying what we can and
in the meantime while we still have it yeah
we have to make the most of this right and
and I think that that's got to be very very
challenging for somebody who has won every
single fight of his life sure and she's watched
him protect the family and win every single
fight and there's nothing he can do yeah yeah
like it's it's a really well drawn character
portrait and I like that after you know I'm
surprised and pleased that after three installments
it still feels I mean we've heard mixed things
about the fourth movie still very excited
to check it out but these three here have
flowed very nicely as just the what feels
authentically like the continuation of a life
and even though they do get more heightened
in ways tonally stylistically it still feels
natural for the world that they've drawn I
still feel like I'm somewhat peering into
history even though yes there is um you know
the cultural propaganda element that people
have pointed out a little in the comments
and height for you know things that are heightened
and fantasized for movies anyway at the end
here though it did it seemed to imply that
the real it man lost his wife to cancer correct
oh yeah I feel like the all these main like
the big major beats are probably all real
things I don't know if he was necessarily
like involved with this mob or whatever like
certain things yeah I would be curious to
know the reality of or is Mike Tyson based
on a real guy or is this just an an opportunity
like even that like I I appreciate the way
they used him I'm kind of curious and interested
by The Format and structure of this movie
as a whole because they do set you up to think
like okay he's gonna be kind of like the the
Twister guy from part two um and that is maybe
the one fight in the movie that does feel
like Mike Tyson's interested in being here
with let's have him in the movies let's do
a fight you know totally but it didn't distract
me I am looking right now at the the Netflix
cover of the Ip Man 3 and that's Mike Tyson
on the right right yeah that's interesting
it's like he's really I mean like how many
days could have been on set yeah I feel like
they could have knocked that out in like a
day or two yeah you know and especially I
know that they do different approaches for
you know this well documented in America you
know shooting action takes longer there's
a lot more uh protocols and and things to
you know make the process as safe as possible
whereas in you know Hong Kong Cinema and Chinese
Cinema and stuff like that you are kind of
just like running and gunning and working
faster hitting harder moving faster in these
fights so I probably bet he could have knocked
it out in a day or two do you think this was
to gain an American audience I'm sure that
was part of it I would imagine I mean like
the way the creators are just big Tyson fans
could be could be and maybe Mike Tyson expressed
some kind of Interest like I would be in feel
free if you guys made it to this point in
the video uh like Enlighten us as to I'm sure
they know at home they're like what happened
to us please yeah yeah here's how he came
to be in the movie but like I I like that
even though it does feel like oh here's a
crossover potential it's just not like a lurid
placement you know it doesn't feel like oh
let's stop the movies so that we can have
a special guest or something like that like
I I thought even though yeah he doesn't really
add a ton yeah he doesn't really add like
a huge amount and he's not like the main focus
of you know the movie or he's not the main
antagonist I still thought that like the way
they used him was kind of interesting in a
way that bolstered the movie rather than taking
away from it again like the structure and
the things I was expecting not ultimately
paying off the way I had expected I think
worked well for me let me ask you a question
I know that there's a fourth one but as it
stands right now as a Trilogy the one two
three that we have seen do you feel like this
is one of the best trilogies yeah this has
been so consistent I I think this is a a beautiful
Trilogy thus far I mean it's each movie has
had I mean you know you never forget the first
time and sort of learning with the first movie
just how this movie is going to express itself
how these movies are going to express themselves
but uh yeah remarkably consistent and uh and
if you asked me to rank him I would be like
that's what I was just thinking about like
because all the jump you kind of think one
has to be first right but my feeling walking
out of two was so strong and then I just feel
like the full circle aspect of and the emotional
side and the relationship side of this one
is so strong I don't know they're so very
even very all if somebody said to me my favorite
man is it man three I wouldn't say what no
I mean I could see like depending on the day
I could see any of them being a favorite because
it's like the first movie you have obviously
the the breadth of excitement and fresh air
just like wow Donnie and as amazing as this
character the fights and all that tonal shift
that we weren't expecting yeah the first one
it's like you get that shift into like oh
damn this is a historical drama of sorts and
then the second one you still have that but
it's like okay now you've got Samo hung here
and now you've got a different antagonist
and you've got you know something that sort
of builds but seems like it's a bit more heightened
uh than the previous one you've got returning
characters and that kind of of to heart and
the experience and then with part three you
have what amounts to something much more intimate
while still you know incorporating some of
those elements and with a couple returning
characters again maybe more gray yeah yes
black and white yeah totally like each one
has its distinct flavor and thus far I think
they've each delivered on great fights uh
really interesting and poised directing both
in those fights and the way the cinematography
has grown like here with you know there's
that above tracking shot on one fight there
are the various little zooms and and ways
that they've enhanced just the capturing of
the choreography yeah it's it's wild because
for me I'm not I'm not not a fight fan but
I'm not like I don't seek out fight movies
so the fact that there's in all three Ip Man
so far there's never been one fight that we've
watched that I was like I wish this wasn't
happening right now could we get back to the
story that's never happened for me every fight
feels fresh and different and Justified and
that's but like wild to me yeah and and yeah
it's like you know if the movie as a whole
isn't working even great action can get a
little mind-numbing and thus far that's never
happened and for me in one of these movies
we'll see what happens in full I know I mean
I'm still rooting for I feel like for my guess
is that four is probably fine because maybe
noticeably not as great as this Trilogy thus
far but who knows this doesn't have his wife
to hold him down I wonder about that I mean
because she even though she is the most prominent
in terms of at least just time focused you
know in this movie right yeah I mean I feel
like things will be different he'll have his
kids older I don't know how Bruce Lee will
factor into the next one and I liked here
that because because so much of what you hear
going into IP man is like oh he's the master
who trained Bruce Lee and so you imagine or
I imagined that like oh so Bruce Lee is gonna
be a big part of these movies and he appears
a couple times here I like that they kept
that thread going of like he's still trying
to convince him and that whole line about
like I didn't open the door I think what he
meant by that was like I opened the door to
communicate that my door is always open not
for you to leave at the time of that happened
I said to you so is that a no and you're like
yeah it seems like a no but to me I didn't
take it as a no and then when he later on
clarifies and says like you misunderstood
or whatever I was thinking like oh you got
it uh-huh that's the second time of the first
time I did you would have been a quicker study
than old Bruce Lee yeah that's what I'm saying
pretty much um faster I would get those cigarettes
and chop the water that see that and like
you know they're great fights with weapons
they're great fights with different sets and
things like that but even that with the cigarettes
I thought was was something that like could
be silly it is a little cheeky but it's part
of too like even though there are so many
kind of harsh and intense elements of these
movies there are still really Charming small
flourishes of humor or of just human personality
and uh yeah I thought that was really fun
and clever I'm with you to me the elevator
fight and the boat fight really stand out
like as two that were like whoa this is new
yeah definitely and and like I love that even
still they seem very inspired and invigorated
to come up with these again just different
ways of showing the array of you know applications
of Wing Chun and and two yeah having it come
down to a fight between them that is only
one audience member who's not even watching
directly plus the kids um but yeah having
just like this really intimate fight at the
end with these big long staffs and these blades
ultimately coming down to just the fists and
then seeing I thought that was fun they they
do the nod to the one inch punch the Bruce
Lee punch that's the ultimate move that finishes
him I think that's what that's supposed to
be uh and so like that was a nice way to keep
that presence that sort of fun I I hesitate
to call it an Easter egg but you could it's
it's a Bruce leester egg at least there's
Easter egg Yeah man so like you know I thought
that was a nice way to keep his presence as
part of this even though yeah you know he's
not like in the fights and he's like he's
in the dancing scene I was like I love those
little subversions too like these are just
so like kind of alive in the way that they're
thought out because I feel like you could
easily kind of autopilot the stories on these
if you wanted to because the fights are so
great and the cast is so great like it's the
other thing is I'm always like man it's like
so lucky that Donnie Yen and everybody involved
are such good Fighters but also can act yeah
yeah yeah totally because if they couldn't
then it would be a disaster you know it was
good because you barely had any coffee to
stay awake and fall asleep like last time
oh yeah that's what happens falling asleep
man movies it's just not not exciting enough
for my American eyes yeah and I've never I
don't know who I believe the actor's name
is uh Jin Zhang who played uh uh Chung but
uh like he I thought had a lot of presence
and and oh my God he was so good yeah I like
the kids too they're very subtle and natural
yeah absolutely it's so nice man this is really
really lovely thanks for doing this with me
man thank you this has been no this has been
such a cool and wonderful Journey I'm very
glad we've been able to bond over this yeah
me too this is one of those things that was
like so unexpected then when Greg was like
I'm pairing you and Roxy up for it man I was
like okay yeah okay okay I have along for
the ride and then yeah and then every time
he's like I got Roxy coming in and I'm like
another rip man he's like yeah I'm like all
right let's go like so you have to text him
this next time and say that you watched four
you couldn't wait so you have to respond Roxy's
just gonna have to do it alone he just couldn't
wait man sorry it needed it that bad absolutely
I just I you know that's me man I'm not a
considerate person you'll find oh I am very
selfish I know I have learned nothing from
these movies yeah that's very Mike Tyson in
this movie it's my role model Frank that's
right man he does look like a Frank with his
face tattoo he for sure does not you know
uh maybe who who knows who could show up here
Jimbo yeah Jimbo or like um or a Craig hi
Craig I could see Craig Cobra Bubbles
[Laughter] what was the deal with the girl
with the balloon and the mom you know I think
it's just one of those contrast pieces of
like I guess that's his his uh Hong Kong honey
and uh yeah like I guess he's they're just
used to him fighting people and that was her
daughter and therefore he he cared about that
okay I couldn't tell if that was his actual
like family here or if he was just like dating
this girl who already had a kid yeah or something
like that he seemed to care at least I don't
know they just were like we're not gonna flush
this out or flush this out and that's fine
there was a lot of like little interstitials
even with characters who aren't like derive
just incidental characters that just kind
of fleshed out the life of people living you
know at the time so I thought that was kind
of one of those things I don't know I guess
this is what Frank's life is about when he's
not busy being a uh you know a Kingpin like
what do you feel like happened to him I don't
know honestly like it feels like he probably
was just able to continue about his business
you think they were trying to leave the door
open for him in four could be then he's not
in four right no idea oh like yeah well I
guess we'll find out yeah we'll be able to
react to that I don't think I've ever heard
you the one two however you do them how do
you do four four four I'll only get it when
it doesn't matter when it comes time to say
for in a in a way that like is in the moment
for the intro or something then you know when
I need it to work it won't work but when I
try to imitate you I do Count Dracula which
is not it Avon that's how I talk okay I in
fact I'm flattered this is if anybody had
to do an impression of me I'm glad that Dracula
is where it goes first I've got you and I'm
the most flattered by that Prospect you're
welcome but hey guys if you've got an impression
of me leave it down below in the comments
or record it and then send it to me and I'll
grade you uh for accuracy and Roxy will grade
you too and if it doesn't sound like The Count
from Sesame Street then you're probably not
on the right track but Roxanne do you have
any other thoughts before we get the hell
out of here just so far so good man so far
so great yeah dude and props to uh Lin shung
who plays uh Wing sing she is so good so like
and I feel like stare at her she's just like
Perfection human she is so poised in love
yeah and like throughout these like I love
that they really gave so much of this movie
to her because she has been such a beautiful
presence in the last two coming into this
behind every fighter this is is a tremendous
you know steady graceful woman if you're lucky
if you're lucky yeah hey Master Chung so for
all of you at home with graceful women you
think you're lucky stars yeah and you know
you sew their buttons on for them instead
of asking them to sew the butt on for real
so the buttons on your damn self but also
for everybody with an IP man at home you think
you're lucky stars too yeah yeah yeah be thankful
of each other and speaking of thankfulness
yes let's let's be thankful for a page
I love the chase all right Chase Gardner Roxy
loves the chase so shout out Chase Garner
what do you guys say Chase Gardner you're
the only uh thing I want to chase I don't
actually want to chase other things except
for you okay see that oh you could be his
wing yeah see the good thing about the name
Chase Gardner too is that Gardener dope yeah
chase you gotta be fast yeah probably a very
Speedy guard that is a good you lucked out
on the name combo there yeah well something
says it's not luck that gets your name people
that make you yeah and they give you the name
well but it's still luck to you yeah that's
true that's true it's not luck to them because
they just came up they just pulled it out
of nowhere but yeah yeah you know but Chase
Mass C and plus it works both ways master
chase sounds cool Master Gardener also sounds
cool master chase Gardener Chase man Chase
man yes I wish people would call me John man
[Music] rocks man rocks man it didn't work
as well it's okay we'll Workshop it we got
one more movie at least and then we got to
move on to other martial arts I guess I guess
that'll be our theme is just martial arts
movie that's all we can do now well Chase
we love you stay pledged and keep walking
that righteous path keep fighting the good
fight and uh thank you when you're ready to
open up your school we'll come train with
you oh yeah be sexy gardening School gardening
School in a cross-country as well cross-country
and gardening yeah obviously they go very
well together love you buddy see you next
time good [Music]